- Dr. Strange,
Captain America,
Ironman.
What do they all have in common?
MCU characters that I'm about to analyze
for their medical accuracy.
Bee-woop.
- Cast you out.
(electric exploding sound)
(time-warp sound)
- That's clearly a case of cosmononotosis
where uh,
the cosmos actually penetrates your skin.
(chuckling)
(thudding)
- I think that was legally your fault.
- Get the first aid kit.
Do me a favor and don't be dead.
(Thor gasping)
- Does he need CPR,
because I totally know CPR.
- Thank you for offering
to do chest compressions,
but a person who is awake
and alert does not need CPR
'cause their heart is beating.
Otherwise they would not be functioning.
- You, what realm is this?
Alphime?
Nornhime?
- New Mexico.
- You dare threaten me?
Thor, you so puny...
(tasering)
- Oh, that's a taser.
Everything in your body is
essentially an electric process.
And when you get zapped with 50,000 volts,
you essentially lose control
of all of those processes.
Therefore you collapse.
- Hi,
just taking a little blood.
- How dare you attack the son of Odin?
- [Doctor] We need some help.
(grunting)
(thudding)
- Oh, I don't want to get hit by Thor.
(crashing and grunting)
- See, if I was in there,
I would be boxing him
like, ah, ah, ah.
- Yo, I got you something.
(beeping)
(grunting)
- You're no match for the Mighty...
(banging)
(glass squeaking)
- That looks like they
gave him a short acting
Benzodiazepine, probably.
Sometimes when we used to do
promethazine and haloperidol,
but the Benzo seemed to work
a little faster and better.
- Ladies and gentlemen.
Today, we take not another
step towards annihilation,
but the first step
towards a path to peace.
We begin with a series of micro injections
into the subject's major muscle groups.
The serum infusion,
will cause immediate cellular change.
- I mean, the reason we
do all our injections,
well, not all our injections.
We do some underneath the skin layer,
but you will also do
intramuscular injections
for things that need
to be rapidly absorbed.
- [Scientist] To stimulate growth,
the subject will be
saturated with (indistinct).
- I hope it's clear that this is fantasy.
There's no thing that you
can inject into muscles
to just make them explode.
The only thing that is somewhat
similar to this is synthol,
which is an oil that I've
talked about in the past
that some TikToker's use
to make their muscles
appear really big,
but they're not functionally big.
Meaning, they're not
stronger by any means.
(suspenseful music)
And that's a huge amount of serum
to inject into each of his little muscles.
Like he's gonna be edematous, if anything.
(pressure releasing)
(triumphant music)
(record scratching)
If you only knew
(whistling)
how many times
(romantic music)
I looked up this image of
his body, in his workout.
So I can get his pecs
because I was obsessed with this look.
Like, this is my dream body right there.
God damn you, Chris.
(triumphant music)
Even the haircut's fire.
(missile exploding)
(missile countdown ticking)
That's a bomb baby.
(missile exploding)
(thudding)
Damage to his tympanic membrane
is definitely happening
with explosion so close to you.
Like, ow,
(futuristic music)
Oh and he's bleeding.
That's not a good area to bleed from,
because that's where the heart is.
(screeching)
(muffled screaming)
Who's performing surgery
with a patient awake?
That's just torture.
(exhaling)
Did they chloroform him?
That's so evil.
And the only reason I say it's evil
is because like,
chloroforming someone by
allowing them to inhale it
by putting a, a, napkin over
it, that's doused in it,
it's not uniform.
You don't know how much
dose you're giving,
you don't know how long they're
gonna be knocked out for.
My worst fear, waking up
in the middle of a surgery.
I think that's everyone's worst fear.
We just don't think about it often.
(suspenseful music)
That's an NG tube.
Not sure why he has an NG tube.
An NG tube is a nasogastric tube that runs
from your nose into your stomach
to either pull fluids out,
or it's to feed him because
he can't eat on his own.
(coughing)
(gasping)
It does come out like that.
So that is accurate.
Just kind of gross watching it.
(ripping and grunting)
(ripping)
(suspenseful music)
And this is where the
medical accuracy ends,
fantasy begins.
- What I did is to save your life.
I removed all the shrapnel I could.
But there's a lot left,
and it's headed into your atrial septum.
- The atrial septum is essentially
the separation between the,
the two top components of the heart.
Now, if there's shrapnel there,
if it's not causing a problem,
I guess you could leave it.
But I don't understand how
it can enter into the septum
and not cause severe bleeding in the heart
between the atria, or at
least out of the atria
into the pericardial space.
- What is this?
- That, is an electromagnet.
Hooked up to car battery,
and it's keeping the shrapnel
from entering your heart.
- Basically what he's saying is,
he's tryna keep the
piece of metal shrapnel
inside the actual meat of the organ,
as opposed to the circulation
part of the organ,
so it doesn't get shot out
into the general circulation
and end up doing more damage.
Like, if it starts going into
the brain, that's lethal.
- Oh my god, is that the thing
that's keeping you alive?
- It was, it is now an antique.
This is what will be keeping me alive
for the foreseeable future.
I'm swapping it out for an upgraded unit.
- I don't know what that
monitor is showing behind.
(chuckling).
- Is it safe?
- Yeah, it should be fun.
It's like operation,
you just don't let it
touch the socket wall.
- What's opera...
What do you mean operation?
- It's just a game, nevermind.
- Great game.
- Okay, great
(monitors beeping).
- Maybe take your ring off first.
- You know, I, I,
I don't think that I'm
qualified to do this.
- Yet you feel qualified to give
very inaccurate advice on goop.com.
Very interesting.
(thudding)
- What is it?
- GSW.
- GSW means gunshot wound.
I don't know why we say GSW
when it's actually more
syllables then gunshot wound.
- It's impinging on the medulla.
I needed a specialist.
Nick diagnosed brain death.
Something about that
doesn't feel right to me.
- We have to run.
- A Bullet in the brainstem
is dangerous for so many reasons.
Mostly because, the
brainstem controls your
respiratory rate, your heart rate,
all these autonomic functions.
If they're not active,
you can't just think,
heartbeat, heartbeat, breathe in,
heartbeat, heartbeat,
breathe in, stomach work.
If they didn't happen
automatically, you die.
- We need to get him prepped
for suboccipital craniotomy.
- Not gonna let you operate on a dead man.
- What do you see?
- A bullet.
- A perfect bullet.
It's been hardened.
You harden a bullet by
alloying lead with antimony,
a toxic metal.
Now that's (indistinct) directly
to the cerebral spinal fluid...
- Rapid onset central
nervous system shutdown.
- We gotta go.
- He's basically saying some
kind of metal from the bullet
is impacting his central nervous system.
Therefore, he's not really dead.
He's acting like he's brain dead.
And he's gonna save his
life by removing the bullet
by doing a radical procedure.
Only in a Marvel movie.
- Cranial nerve's intact.
- Those look like alligator forceps.
I love using those to get ear
wax out of patient's ears,
especially when it's like
hard and you could go in there
and just, like grab it.
Hmmm, so satisfying.
(clock ticking)
Okay, okay this is really funny.
This is really, really funny.
And I'm not a surgeon,
I've never worn this device,
but looking at this image,
the things he's wearing on his
glasses to get a better view,
are they not covering his field of vision?
And then the actual lenses
are lower than his eyes.
Oh my God, he can't see through those.
(car engine roaring)
- Can you send me the...
(notification pinging)
Got it.
(cars crashing)
(tires screeching)
- Who wants a surgeon that
is getting pictures of patient records
on their Lamborghini and
then crashing their car?
(dramatic music)
(glass shattering)
(inhaling deeply)
- Looks like he has a lot
of fractures in his hands
requiring some kind of orthopedic device
with pins and needles.
I, I've never seen it on
the outside like this.
This is very exaggerated.
But remember, the bones in
the hand are quite small.
The carpals are very small.
So, putting in pins is not
always a simple process,
especially the big size
pins that they have there.
(rain pouring)
(melancholic music)
It's gonna take a lot of physical therapy.
So shout out to physical therapists.
But also, occupational therapists as well.
Because when it comes
to rehabbing the hands,
you gotta think about fine motor control.
Especially for him as a surgeon.
- [Doctor] Show me your strength.
(mystical music)
- This is him getting that
therapy I was just talking about.
- [Dr. Strange] This is useless.
- If the patient is struggling this much,
we have to decrease the intensity
of whatever therapy we're doing.
It's about be,
allowing them to do it
successfully several times,
and then increasing that
intensity as time goes on.
- Have you ever known anyone
with nerve damage this severe,
to do this and actually recover?
- One guy, yeah.
Factory accident.
Broke his back, paralyzed,
his leg wasted away.
He came in three times a week.
A few years later, he walked
past me on the street.
- Walked?
- [Other Guy] Ya, walked.
- Show me his file.
- It'll me a while to pull
the files from the archive.
- You can't just show people
patient records, come on guy.
HIPAA.
- But if it proves your
arrogant ass wrong...
- He is an arrogant ass.
And as a surgeon, like Dr. Strange,
you should know that people recover from
severe strokes,
traumas,
tumors,
and regain neurological function.
The progress that patients
make under the care of PMNR,
Physical Medicine and
Rehabilitation Physicians,
is truly magical.
It goes to show that the human body
has an amazing capacity to heal itself.
That's the principle
of osteopathic medicine
that we live by.
And it's not because
I love that principle,
It's because it's true.
- Christine
(grunting)
- Steven?
Oh my god, what...
- You need to get me in
an operating theater, now.
Just you.
Now, I haven't any time.
- You can't just run into a hospital
and request an operating theater.
- What happened?
- Stabbed, cardiac tamponade.
- How does he know he
has cardiac tamponade?
If you've been stabbed,
you can actually die
from cardiac tamponade.
But how he knows that
without doing an echo,
listening for heart sounds,
and all this other stuff, I have no idea.
- Chest cavity's clear.
- I don't know what she just did
to know that the chest cavity is clear.
She went...
(pinging)
(beeping)
(mystical music)
(Dr. Strange breathing)
Okay, this is the non-medically
accurate part of the show.
(dramatic music)
If someone has pneumothorax
where their lung collapses
and you're sure of it,
you could put a needle into
the second intercostal space,
which will allow you to
allow that air to come out,
normalizing the pressure,
allowing their lung to re-expand.
(suspenseful music)
Whoa, we don't do it like that, bro.
Can you imagine if we
just like, are like, okay,
I'm putting it in.
And you have to make sure
you're palpating the area as you do it.
You're not just like stabbing
randomly from far away.
Like, by holding it from so far away,
you have very little control
of where you're actually
putting the needle.
(medical machine beeping)
(suspenseful music)
Okay, he's flat lining.
If she takes out the paddles,
I will scream.
(suspenseful music)
She's taking out the paddles!
Stop charging them, you
don't shock asystole!
Chest compressions,
chest compressions,
chest compressions!
(indistinct)
(beeping)
Clearly they need this.
This is the chest
compressions university merch.
Two inches deep,
a hundred per minute.
Please do chest compressions
when someone's heart stops,
not run to shock them.
You could also buy this merch down below.
(notification beeping)
Here's the truth about your underwear.
Click here to check that out.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
But, is your underwear healthy?
Click here to check that out.
(upbeat music)